hola a todos muchísimas gracias por
asistir a esta plática soy jorge ferrer
de jorge ferrer consultores mx es un
gusto estar con ustedes hoy mi plática
va a tratar de cómo es que los
emprendedores son los que vamos a
cambiar al mundo a través del
emprendimiento de alto impacto
quiero darte una metáfora antes de
empezar
el avión cuando despega va contra el
viento ningún avión despega con el
viento favor
lo mismo que el salmón cuando nada nada
contracorriente los emprendedores somos
iguales vamos a contracorriente
vamos contra el gobierno vamos contra la
sociedad vamos contra la marea vamos
contra los cambios vamos contra la
economía no en un método revolucionario
sino en un método que nos toca ir a
contracorriente nos toca cambiar al
mundo nos toca innovar en los productos
no nos toca cambiar las tendencias
déjame darte unos datos antes de que
empecemos con la plática
tú sabías que el 60% de los
emprendedores facturan menos de 500 mil
pesos al año y que solo el 80 por ciento
alcanza a vender menos de un millón de
pesos al año eso quiere decir que hay un
20% que logra vender muchísimo más de un
millón y en esos emprendedores son los
que nos tenemos que fijar y en esos
emprendedores son los que nos tenemos
que convertir 75 por ciento de los que
emprendan van a quebrar en los primeros
tres años pero hay un 25 por ciento que
va a sobrevivir esa estadística la
tenemos que cambiar esa estadística
tenemos que aumentar ese 25 por ciento
en un 35 40 50 por ciento permíteme
compartirte dos historias de
emprendimiento de alto impacto para que
nos pongamos en contexto de a qué me
refiero
andrés garcía fundó la empresa crisol
este chavo
quería cambiar el impacto de la que
estamos teniendo en el planeta a través
de la gran contaminación que hacemos y
él investigó y estuvo viendo las maneras
de cómo poder revertir el cambio
climático y se dio cuenta que uno de los
grandes contaminantes que tenemos es la
quema de llantas la quema de neumáticos
usados entonces este chavo inventó un
proceso mediante el cual recibe todas
las llantas usadas las tritura y las
convierte en materias primas nuevamente
sin necesidad de quemarlas su
emprendimiento de alto impacto además de
esta relación lo rico que es todo un
cambio
en la salud del planeta pero además de
eso sin saberlo descubrió que había
tristemente en méxico un mercado negro
que utilizaba estas llantas para
revenderlas esto generaba accidentes
muertos lisiados su emprendimiento logró
reducir estos números otra persona de la
que te quiero platicar es gabriela león
esta chica es egresada de la unam yx
tapalapa e inventó un desinfectante tan
poderoso que hoy es utilizado en más de
140 países
su desinfectante elimina virus bacterias
y esporas en espacios cerrados lo mismo
que el cloro con una gran diferencia el
cloro dura hasta 30 minutos mientras que
el desinfectante de esta niña dura hasta
72 horas
es importante que sepas que el
desinfectante de esta niña fue pieza
clave para la contención de la epidemia
del ébola en áfrica ves como un
emprendedor se puede tener un impacto
enorme en el mundo una sola persona un
solo producto un solo servicio puede
cambiar el mundo
recuerda qué
grandes corporaciones de hoy en día como
lo son facebook y google empezaron como
un emprendimiento porque digo que son
los emprendedores los que van a gestar
el gran cambio porque lo han sido en el
pasado hoy son grandes corporaciones y
las grandes corporaciones no pueden
gestar ese cambio porque son demasiado
grandes no se pueden mover tan rápido
google facebook cortar and gamble
kimberly clark cocacola
sus presupuestos multimillonarios de
medios les permiten llegar y viralizar
un producto una noticia en cuestión de
minutos pero emprendedores como los que
acabo de decir les toma mucho tiempo y
mucho trabajo
facundo cabral que es una persona que yo
admiro mucho un cantautor
y gran poeta tenía una frase maravillosa
que decía la bomba hace más ruido y
destruye más que una caricia pero por
cada bomba que destruye hay cientos de
miles de caricias que construyen lo
mismo sucede con los emprendedores y las
grandes corporaciones somos más los
emprendedores pero no somos menos nos
vemos menos los gobiernos
desgraciadamente no van a gestar el
cambio los gobiernos están enfrascados
en la burocracia en la seguridad de la
nación
los temas electorales en las reformas
que se tienen que hacer para bien o para
mal del país
pero no pueden gestar un cambio el
cambio está en nosotros en los
emprendedores y tenemos que dejar de
pensar en el emprendimiento del
changarro tenemos que pensar en
emprendimientos de alto impacto como los
de estos dos chicos que te quiero
compartir si tú vas a emprender por
favor responderte un pequeño
cuestionario antes de hacerlo
evidentemente haz todo lo que la teoría
te dice tu business plan tu plan
financiero tengas tu metodología de
hecho tu plan de negocios pero además
contestaste el siguiente cuestionario
qué problemática resuelve mi
emprendimiento qué beneficios tiene mi
emprendimiento en mi familia en mi
círculo y en la sociedad en la que me
desenvuelvo qué beneficios tiene para mi
estado y para mi país
qué beneficios tiene para el mundo
que pierde el mundo sin emprendimiento
no sale a la luz
cuántos empleos directos puede generar
mi emprendimiento cuántas personas van a
alcanzar la libertad financiera gracias
a mi emprendimiento muy importante voy a
alcanzar la libertad financiera con mi
emprendimiento una vez que tengas
resuelto este cuestionario por favor
asegúrate de emprender y si le pegas
tengo un mensaje muy importante para ti
y quizá el más trascendente de esta
plática detrás de ti vienen miles de
emprendedores por favor tienes la mano y
ayuda a los porque los emprendedores
cuando nacemos al emprendimiento somos
ignorantes tenemos miedos no conocemos
todas las leyes
tenemos que ser abogados fiscalistas
vendedores contadores mercadólogos
repartidores cargadores
tú que ya estás más arriba tienes la
mano y ayúdanos quiero compartir te
y pongámonos de acuerdo en lo que el
emprendimiento alto impacto va a cambiar
qué es lo que va a cambiar y por qué es
un cambio positivo en el mundo no vamos
a acabar con la pobreza eso sería
utópico pero podemos acabar con el
desempleo podemos combatir el desempleo
podemos asegurarnos que cada persona que
quiera trabajar porque no todas quieren
trabajar tengan una oportunidad
podemos combatir los productos que son
nocivos para la salud a través de
emprender a través de innovar a través
de crear productos que nos ayuden a
reducir el consumo de productos nocivos
solo el emprendimiento y solo los
emprendedores vamos a cambiar el mundo
no me cansaré de decírtelo en esta
plática ni me cantaré decirlo allá
afuera
ojalá y todos los que están viendo esta
plática se animen a emprender si
emprendes cuentas conmigo soy jorge
ferrer muchísimas gracias por invitarme
muchas gracias a ted talks y al anáhuac
por lanzar en esta oportunidad